I did want to talk you really quick
about the show shrinking yeah which is
so amazing how far into shooting do you
guys realize like this is different this
is special the first time we did the
table read
I was sitting next to Harrison Ford and
then Jason was there and the table read
was so incredible I've never been to a
table read like that like it gave me
goosebumps I was like I think this show
is really special and then I would
sometime like one time Jason turns me
and goes is it me or is this show it's
been a privilege I'm so grateful to be
working on that show something a lot of
people may not know about you because I
know this is some news that I learned is
that you actually do a lot of music
supervision uh for some of these shows
too Ted lasso shrinking Cougar Town and
scrubs I did as well Gary would would be
with me on this one it's the most fun
job well especially when you probably
have developed um art new artists when
you find somebody no one's ever heard of
and you throw them on the show and they
get famous and it kind of vindicates
your thinking and you're helping her
career oh it's the best part art also I
had Ben Gibbard from Death Cab for Cutie
he did the theme song for us and he said
to me you know when you put our song on
Scrubs and we were nowhere not only did
we have the song launch it gave us that
cash to kind of get through and get more
equipment that we needed and gave us a
cushion and it's so helpful for new
artists Howard's got uh his new band
took us I believe their latest single is
metal mucil man you think you'd be able
to work that into one of your shows yeah
I mean I think that definitely should be
in the show in some capacity it would
work for it would work for almost
anything with Harrison any scene any
scene at all
foreign